[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du cetud culture et tout de suite
le sommaire de ce mercredi 12 avril la
france la suisse la belgique et le
canada 4 pays pour un titre le mondial
de l'impro se joue cette année attrape
des couleurs vives pour des sujets
uppercut depuis 70 ans bernard rancillac
dans l'actualité
quelques-unes de ses toiles sont
actuellement exposées à la maison
triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines est un
festival qui renaît de ses cendres ou
presque une dizaine de groupes sera
voisins le bretonneux le 1er juillet
prochain pour la tour mais les ouates
ils ont entre 15 et 19 ans ils sont
français suisses belges et québécois et
durant quatre jours ils vont s'affronter
avec les mots vous allez voir à l'image
les juniors de déclic ont vu leur
dernier entraînement lundi mardi les
québécois étaient accueillis par leurs
homologues français
leurs armes ce sont les mots et le rire
du 13 au 16 avril c'est la troisième
édition du mondial de l'impot junior et
cet attrape que ça se passe ecoutez-nous
reignac et louise le responsable du
secteur improvisation de d'équipé at il
deux joueurs si l'initiative des belges
genre
laurence a quand même ceux qui
organisent le premier mondial
et du coup ils sont voilà nous ont
contactés par mail en me disant voilà
qu'est ce que vous en pensez si on se
disait qu'on faisait ça et qu'on essaye
de le relancer tous les ans voilà hier
roberto sierra qui est sur les starting
block canada
est ce que ça vous dit bah on a dit
ouais on voit on a répondu positivement
on n'allait pas et pousse et avoir le
même sens bien ça se passe bien il ya
toujours un bon esprit d'équipé
c'est ça aussi qui fait qui fait notre
force c'est qu'on est soudée solidaire
donc on travaille comme il faut à
l'entraînement
il n'y a pas d'appréhension
et tout se passe très bien pour
l'instant c'est différent parce qu'ils
n'ont pas du tout le même style de jeu
que nous a parlé belle on a à peu près
le même jeu mais les suisses et des
québécois on n'a pas du tout le même
style de jeu mais on arrive quand même à
se comprendre ce qu'on a promise quand
même donc c'est ça qui nous relient il
est l'un des fondateurs du mouvement de
la figure anar hâtive bernard rancillac
pain l'actualité et ses personnages des
tableaux ou au en couleur où
l'engagement de l'auteur se lit dans
chaque coup de pinceau quelques-unes de
ses oeuvres sont exposées à la maison
triolet aragon jusqu'au 14 mai regardez
des chefs d'état rail est caricaturé
ridiculiser avec en faire part a dit
bernard rancillac peint des personnages
marquants du 20e siècle
l'artiste français crocs depuis 70 ans
l'histoire avec un regard acerbe
c'est un rebelle c'est un homme
passionné qui a toujours pris position
qui est un qui est engagée à sa manière
c'est un peintre qui travaille à partir
de photographies ou à partir d'image
c'est à dire que si vous voulez c'est un
pain qui a beaucoup réfléchi dans les
années 60 70 du siècle dernier au rôle
de la photographie dans les magazines
rancillac dit au fond nous ne savons
plus regarder le monde tel qu en lui
même nous ne regardons plus qu'avec des
photos qu'à travers des photos qui
peuplent nos mémoires ce qu'il préfère
c'est montrer la vie bernard rancillac
utilise la couleur vive pour attirer
l'oeil et faire réfléchir à l'actualité
maintenant il peint à l'acrylique c'est
à dire une toile qui est une peinture
qui est venu dans le commerce
andreu au milieu des années 60 qu'il a
tout de suite adopté parce qu'elle sèche
très vite c'est à dire que vous
commencez une toile le matin vous pouvez
voir le soir même ce que ça
ce que ça donne et quand vous peignez
l'actualité que vous payez à partir de
photos et que vous êtes un homme pressé
comme rancillac et bien évidemment saadé
ça a des avantages
une quinzaine de toiles retrace la
carrière de bernard rancillac
l'exposition yvelinoise complète la
rétrospective proposée actuellement par
le musée de la poste à l'espace niemeyer
à paris une deuxième exposition à
découvrir ou à redécouvrir il ne faut
pas traîner car c'est ce sont ces
derniers jours banlieue banlieue à
guyancourt
le collectif du même nom présente une
cinquantaine de ses oeuvres avec photos
et documents d'époque
la dizaine de jeunes artistes qui
composent le collectif a façonné le
paysage urbain des années 80 avec ses
fresques
ici on voit pas le travail éphémère
c'est à dire les fresques les grands
grands formats qui était un peu notre
particularité est une des grandes
particularités c'était de peindre à
plusieurs les mêmes supports alors ici
on voit des toiles donc finalement c'est
une expo un peu plus classique
mais c'est un reflet c'est comme un peu
des extraits de ce qu'on pouvait mettre
dans la rue 2011 c'était la 12e et
dernière édition de la tour prend l'air
le festival de musique penser par mes
tassos cinq ans plus tard l'association
vie sinoise a décidé de relancer un
festival son nom la tour 1 mais les
ouates
le rendez vous est pris pour le 1er
juillet un point sur la programmation le
temps je ne suis qu'un l'âge j'ignore le
nom d' ses idéaux comme un porc sans
roulage
une programmation éclectique pour la
salle de la tour
après cinq ans d'absence un nouveau
festival va voir le jour à voisins le
bretonneux
j'étais dernier on s'est dit pourquoi on
ferait pas quelque chose allez on remet
ça cette année on a décidé de mettre les
voix qui c'est à dire que la salle de la
tour de l'euro prend l'air et cette
année on veut mettre un peu plus de
puissance
donc voilà pourquoi on met les ouates de
scène du reggae du rock du punk une
journée de concerts et une tête
d'affiché à l'acte round
[Musique]
m
light râble qui cartonne en ce moment
depuis 20 ans c'est une scène française
voilà qui propose vraiment cette musique
natural trance
donc voilà dans l'univers un peu techno
mais vraiment avec les instruments je
vois les vrais instruments qu'ils ont
leurs patins eu assez unique et je pense
que voilà le public commence à bien
connaître ce groupe est allé suivre
c'est vraiment enfin l'ambiance en
concert est excellente
[Musique]
des groupes indépendants et des groupes
locaux ils seront une dizaine à voisins
le bretonneux
rendez vous le 1er juillet pour près de
10 heures de concert musique encore ils
sont plus que 2 met l'accent chantant
est toujours là mouss et hakim qui était
membre du groupe zebda forme maintenant
les motiver ils seront sur la scène de
la merise le 21 avril prochain et on
écoute un titre des toulousains
[Musique]
m
il faut se montrer
[Musique]
un moment littérature à présent
l'association plaisir aux lectures et
dialogues accueille un nouvel écrivain
pour une conférence le 20 avril le
prochain c'est eric faye qui échangera
avec ses lecteurs il est journaliste de
profession et s'intéresse aux romans et
récits de voyage la semaine prochaine il
présentera donc ses deux derniers
ouvrages nagasaki qui est le grand prix
du roman de l'académie française et
éclipse japonaise écoutez le j'ai vécu
au japon en 2012 là dans le cadre d'une
résidence d'écrivain à la villa kujoyama
à kyoto
et c'est là que j'ai fait des recherches
pour le dernier roman éclipse japonaise
comme ce qui me plaît que j'y vais
régulièrement je fais attention
d'informations de toutes natures qui
peuvent venir à propos du japon et mon
autre métier c'est d'être journaliste
dans une agence de presse et je vois
beaucoup d'informations qui viennent du
monde entier
je fait particulièrement attention une
nouvelle qui viennent de l'asie et du
japon
et comme chaque semaine c'est le moment
de notre coup de coeur cinéma cette
semaine on part aux yeux d'elsa de
saint-cyr-l'ecole écouter alors cette
semaine au cinéma les yeux d'elsa le
coup de coeur c'est la programmation de
la semaine parce que c'est le reflet de
la diversité qu'on souhaite proposer à
commencer par la belle et la bête qu'il
est inutile de présenter le dernier
disney donc ensuite le film moonlight
film américain oscarisé sur le parcours
en 3 h d'un jeune homosexuel d'un
quartier de miami
un film vraiment sensible et rayonnant
qu'on vous invite à voir en version
originale ensuite paris pinula comédie
burlesque de duos fiona gordon et bruno
romy un duo de comédiens acrobates dans
une jolie comédie douce et acidulées et
enfin s'il ne fallait retenir qu'un film
ce serait chez nous de lucas belvaux une
fable politique sur l'ascension d'un
parti d'extrême droite qui se refait une
respectabilité en allant chercher une
jeune infirmière qui est formidablement
interprété par emilie dequenne
alors tous nos horaires sont sur le site
allociné et vous pouvez trouver le
programme complet sur le site de la
ville de saint cyr l'école
on débute nos rendez vous avec un rendez
vous musical un hommage au chanteur pop
pop et funk des années 70 80
pierre de bethmann et linley marthe
seront en concert le 18 avril prochain
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
après le théâtre comme espace coluche et
les bourreaux voilà à saint quentin en
yvelines
cette fois c'est sur la scène du prisme
à elancourt qui accueillent ces sept
apprentis enquêteurs
les faux british mais l'histoire d'amour
et enquête policière regarder mais je
vais avoir besoin de chacun de vos
témoignages
plus tôt je commencerai mon enquête plus
tôt j'aurais délai laissé de souris soir
maintenant je vous jure que c'est vous
qui avez écrit cette lettre mais j'avoue
certainement elle a été écrite
proprement y avait six élèves vous y
avez tout l'amour que vous avez pour lui
et que j'ai dit écrit beaucoup
perspective de ce mariage avec son temps
j'avais du mal est vous l'avez vous
trouvé dans sa poche tout simplement
alors servi la gu
un autre rendez vous celui de claire
fouquet qui a plusieurs amours le dessin
l'aquarelle la gravure et l'animation
l'artiste touche-à-tout expose son
travail à partir du 17 avril au
conservatoire des arts de montigny le
bretonneux et on termine avec cette fois
un spectacle pour les plus jeunes à
montigné le public pourra découvrir
comment jean de la fontaine a écrit ces
fables à la demande de louis xiv mais
c'est une ambiance plus tim burton que
grand siècle qui vous attend le cette
huile culture est maintenant terminée je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez retrouver ce magazine en replay
sur notre site internet www pointer les
chais 78 points comme renfort
non